take a look at yourself
are you a very old baby
or
a baby like old person
uh oh
your biological clock is moving backward
what would your body look like at
different stages of life
how could it change the ways you
interact with other people
and could you eventually shrink down
until you
disappeared
this is what f and here's what would
happen if you aged backward
now if you've seen the curious case of
benjamin button you watched brad pitt
grow from an old man baby into a baby
like older man
but this condition is somewhat different
in real life
progeria or
hutchinson-gilford syndrome is a rare
genetic disorder that causes children to
age fast after they turn two years old
their physical growth slows dramatically
they lose their hair and many of them
die around age 13.
even though it's not really like the
story progeria is commonly called
benjamin button disease
but in the spirit of keeping things
light
let's give you the hollywood experience
but be warned
your life wouldn't be as glamorous
aging backward would give you a glimpse
into what your future self could have
been but
what if you could alter your fate and
the world today
get ready for the immersive and
multi-layered experience of future now
it's the year 2084
humans dominate the solar system
artificial intelligence rules our lives
and
five factions battle for our fate
future now unravels the mysteries of
this hopeful and
often frightening society that mirrors
our world today
and you're not just watching a series of
videos as this universe unfolds
you're part of an interactive community
collaborating with our creators
molding the story lines through
discussions polls and so much more
yeah that's right humanity's fate is in
your hands
are you ready
subscribe and join the growing online
community creating the next steps in
human evolution on earth and beyond the
stars
don't let others decide your destiny
choose who you will become and explore
the world of future now
your birth would be mostly unremarkable
as your mom and dad get their first
glimpse of their beautiful baby
they wouldn't be concerned by your
crinkled old looking face
babies can look a bit funny right
but from this point on everything would
change
you'd quickly grow from the size of a
baby to the size of a small adult
this would be a shock for your parents
from one day to the next their baby
turned into an older adult with dry skin
brittle bones and wispy gray hair
like other babies you'd have a
vulnerable immune system limited mental
development and you'd cry a lot but
you'd be crying from the aches of
arthritis
your parents would have to be extra
cautious when holding you to not break
any of your fragile bones
by your first birthday you'd appear to
be in your mid-70s but
you wouldn't be telling stories to your
grandkids
you'd barely know how to talk yet
the rest of your childhood would be
anything but ordinary too
cognitively you'd be as young as your
peers but you'd look like a retiree
the pains of growing younger would
continue into your teens
while other kids your age are going
through puberty you'd experience a lot
of the same feelings
i'm too old to be young
but since you'd look about 60 years old
it could be tough to ask your crush out
on a date
even when you're 18 dating would be
weird
dating people your age would spark a lot
of conversations but going out with
middle-aged people who look your
physical age would be hard too
you wouldn't have the sexual or life
experiences that someone in their 50s
might be looking for
and you would only be beginning your
professional life so you wouldn't have
much money to go out on fancy grown up
dates
you'd also have nearly no work
experience but you'd look like you were
nearing the end of your career potential
employers wouldn't understand why you
seem so inexperienced and unqualified
for jobs
as you approach your 30s you might feel
more or less normal for the first time
in your life
sure you'd look a lot older than most of
your friends but you could finally blend
in at around age 37.
the real challenge now would be facing
reality again
if you have a romantic partner you might
feel you're on different journeys
at 50 you'd have had a lot of life
experience but you'd look like a recent
college graduate so people wouldn't be
inclined to believe you
i don't believe it job interviews would
be strange again because employers might
think you're a little too confident for
your age
you and your partner could have trouble
going out together because others would
see an age gap between you
in private your sex drives would likely
be out of sync
you'd be in the physical prime of your
life while your partner's libido would
start slowing down
finally you'd be entering old age and
your life would be
weird again
you could be a grandparent but you'd
look the same age as your grandkids
that could be tricky to explain to them
and as you reach the end of your life
you'd need a lot of help
you'd experience problems with your
memory and physically you'd be losing
your fine motor skills
your children would probably need to
feed you and carry you everywhere
but you'd be really cute
your death would be truly bizarre
and while there are several ways you
could go
maybe you'd continue growing younger and
younger
shrinking cell by cell
eventually
you'd just be gone
well you had a unique life
you learned a lot about facing
challenges since you were usually out of
sync with everyone else your birth age
maybe it would be better if you somehow
stayed young forever
but
that's a story
for another
what if
hmm